Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
was supposed to be a graceful swan song
for The Beloved Adventure hero but it
instead seems to have been a poor choice
here's why it's not clicking with
audiences like expected although the box
office numbers are disappointing
according to variety dial of Destiny
pulled in an 82 million domestic gross
over its first five days of release with
a production budget of nearly 300
million dollars the movie is actually
doing pretty well in terms of its
critical reception it has settled at a
68 rating on the Rotten Tomatoes Tomato
Meter giving it fresh status and it has
an overwhelmingly positive audience
score of 88 percent but Indy's final
Adventure started things off on the
wrong foot with its early reviews
foreign
star Harrison Ford premiered the movie
at the 76th annual Cannes Film Festival
the critical reactions from that showing
were mixed to negative critics including
Owen gleiverman a variety and Manola
dargis of the New York Times wrote about
their disappointment regarding various
elements of the film such as its generic
Blockbuster movie feel and uneven plot
for several weeks the Ken reaction
dominated the conversation surrounding
the movie's quality that early negative
Buzz certainly didn't do the movie any
favors in its pre-release marketing even
if it did ultimately turn out to be far
more warmly received by those that
bothered to go see it dial of Destiny
isn't the first time that Hollywood has
attempted to resurrect this storied
franchise in 2008 nearly two decades
after the Last Crusade came Indiana
Jones and the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull the fourth film in the series
attempted to move the story forward
placing an older and wiser version of
Indy in the midst of a 1950s conspiracy
narrative full of Cold War Intrigue fans
weren't too happy with the result
decrying the film's formulaic approach
to recreating the spectacle of the
original movies they also didn't love
questionable new elements like the
character of Plucky youngster Mutt
Williams played by Shia LaBeouf who
notably doesn't return for dial of
Destiny for some viewers Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull was proved that the
Indiana Jones franchise would be better
off left to rest in the Glory Days of
old
knowledge was their treasure
it's unlikely then that those fans will
be convinced to watch a second Revival
in dial of Destiny no matter how much of
an improvement it may be
dialect Destiny is far from the only
movie of its kind to have underperformed
this year there are other examples from
even the same month of release June 2023
DC's massive superhero Blockbuster The
Flash similarly bombed at the box office
and Pixar's Elemental also vastly
underperformed all of these movies are
major Productions attached to big
studios and intended to appeal to
General audiences it seems the dial of
Destiny is facing some issues that are
endemic to the greater industry while
there's no definitive answer to the
problem plaguing the Blockbuster movie
scene at the moment there are a few
factors to consider theaters have
somewhat managed to recover from their
struggles from the kova 19 pandemic but
there are still Ripple effects would be
moviegoers seem to be more selective
regarding which movies can draw them
back into darkened theaters full of
other people there's also the matter of
franchise fatigue the general landscape
of the film industry is currently filled
with all manner of sequels nostalgic
revivals reboots and action-packed
superhero flicks and it's possible that
the luster of a new Indiana Jones movie
among other franchise Fair has been
consider iterably dulled the fact of the
matter is that not everyone who wants to
see dial of Destiny is going to do so in
theaters yes the film debuted
exclusively in cinemas but it's only a
matter of time until it becomes
available to stream at home and
interested viewers may be content to
wait until then to watch it there's
currently no set date for when dial of
Destiny will become available to watch
at home through Disney plus and other
services but there probably won't be too
long of a wait if precedent holds most
recent Disney movies including as
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania and
black panther wakanda forever arrived on
Disney plus and other digital
storefronts somewhere around 90 days
after their theatrical release that
means that audiences likely only have to
wait a matter of months until dial of
Destiny is available to watch in the
comfort of their homes
[Music]